le 15 avril 2009 est une date charnière
dans la lutte contre les hells angels
156 motards étaient visés par
l'opération
les cinq chapitres démantelé et les cinq
repaire des motards saisie sur le
terrain les policiers jubilaient
le but de l'opération c'est bien évident
c'est d'enrayer de paralyser les
activités communales des hells angels la
poursuite disposer d'une preuve
monumental notamment parce que la police
a de recruter un témoin spécial
le sergent d'armes dr sylvain boulanger
qui avait raconté tous les secrets de
l'organisation à l'etat en échange on
lui offrait presque 3 millions de
dollars pour son témoignage
mais l'opération réussie du 15 avril
2009 s'est embrouillé au fil des ans et
s'est conclue par un fiasco judiciaire
boulanger n'a jamais témoigné pourtant
la police et la poursuite avait pris la
précaution de s'assurer auprès des
autorités que le système judiciaire
était prêt à absorber l'opération sharqc
qui était calqué sur l'opération
printemps 2001
huit ans plus tôt qui avait fonctionné
on avait eu deux mégots procès qui avait
très bien fonctionné on avait eu de bons
résultats au niveau des condamnations
c'est qu'on ne pouvait pas se douter
d'un échec révisée en 2011
la couronne essuie un premier revers 31
accusés sont libérés de toutes les
accusations par le juge qui prévoit que
les délais avant de subir leur procès
seront trop long ensuite la plupart des
accusés toujours en prison plaide
coupable à des accusations réduites en
le seul procès découlant de l'opération
sharqc s'ouvre enfin
mais après moins de deux mois le juge
prononce l'arrêt des procédures
la couronne a commis une faute
irréparable en transmettant tardivement
des éléments de preuve à la défense
l'opération sharqc finit de façon
désastreuse
après avoir coûté des dizaines de
millions de dollars à l'état québécois
après deux enquêtes administratives
québec conclut que les mégaprocès sont
des paquebots quasi impossible à
manoeuvrer et qu'il faut revoir la façon
de procéder
depuis les motards ont repris le terrain
perdu 5 aujourd'hui
c'est un recul policiers on travaille
comme dans les années 90 c'est à dire
des plus petits losier qui mène après un
ou deux en arcade à l'arrestation de
peut-être un an ou deux membres en règle
donc si tu es non mais c'est impossible
d'anéantir les dodgers de cette façon là
depuis 2016
les hells angels n'ont presque plus deux
rivaux et il trompe tout en haut de la
pyramide criminelle sur le front
judiciaire ils ont entrepris des
poursuites civiles contre le
gouvernement qu'il tienne responsables
de leur détention qu'il qualifie d'
injustifié ici isabelle richer radio
canada montréal